字幕: Kana Yamato
校正: Takaya Asai
早速なんですけど
皆さん ご飯食べている時に
目の前に美味しそうな小籠包が
１つだけ余っているとします
それ 食べますか？
それとも 他の人が
食べたいんじゃないかと思って
手を出せないですか？
こういう場面って たぶん誰もが
経験したことがあると思うんですね
僕らの日常の生活の中には
こういった様々な
選択をする場面っていうのがあります
「思ったことを言葉にする」
頭ではわかってるんですけど
いざ言おうと思ったら 言えないとか
そんなことってありますよね
勇気を出して人に伝えるって
なかなか難しいです
タイミングが わからなくて
伝えられないとか
あと 空気を読まないと
嫌われちゃうんじゃないかとか
波風を立てない方が
いいんじゃないのとか思って
ついつい遠慮しちゃいます
様々な不安っていうのが
僕たちの中にはあります
僕自身もそういうことを感じる時があります
僕はここ札幌で生まれ育ちました
３歳になる頃にはもう
クリエイティブディレクターの
血が目ざめてたんですけど…
（笑）
16歳でアメリカに留学しました
アメリカに行ったばかりの時は
自分の思ったこととか やりたいことを
全然伝えられなくて
数々の挫折とか
後悔とかを経験しました
だから今 僕はできるだけ
思ったこととか やりたいことを
人に伝えるようにしています
さっきの小籠包の話だと
「食べるよ！」とか言ってパクって食べたり
「これ食べないの？」とか
人に勧めるとか
とにかく相手に対して
伝えるようにしてます
そんな海外の経験とかで
学んだことの一つに
「思ったことを言わないのは
思っていないのと同じ」
ということがあります
これは決して わがままになろうよとか
めちゃくちゃなことを言って下さい
ということではないです
あくまでも
自分の思いを相手に伝えないと
「もったいないよ」というふうに
捉えてください
例えば「僕だったらこうするのにな」とか
「やり方わかんないから教えて」とか
シンプルなことで言うと
ありがとうとか
ごめんねっていうことを
ちゃんと相手に言ってくってことが
大事だと 僕は思っています
僕は普段 先ほども
紹介していただいたんですが
広告のクリエイターとして
働いています
広告のクリエイターって
様々な企業や社会の
課題を解決する そんな仕事です
まあ ちょっと広告クリエイターと聞くと
キラキラしてて
自由にものづくりしてるっていうイメージを
持たれる方もいるかもしれないんですけど
どっちかっていうと
色々な制限とかルールとか
約束の中で
ものづくりをするっていう
日々 格闘している
もがき苦しみながら
ものづくりをしてる
そんな毎日を過ごしています
制限やルールですね
僕たちの生活の中には沢山あります
時間とか お金とか
体力とかリソースみたいな
人間の部分もあります
こういったものと日々 格闘しながら
僕たちは世界を前に動かしています
僕も そういった制限があると
「突き抜けた表現をしよう」とか
「今まで誰も見たことないもの作ろう」
みたいなことが
難しくなったり
時にできなくなってしまいます
なので そんな壁を突破するために
僕はあるものを作っています
それが「野望リスト」というものです
野望リストは 僕たちが想像する
あらゆるやりたいことっていうのを
とにかく ひたすら
書きまくろうっていうリストです
こんなことやりたい
あんなことやりたいというのを
書きまくります
そしてそれを仲間に共有します
そこがすごく大事です
僕たちが思っている
やりたいことを とにかく書いて共有する
とてもシンプルで
誰にでもできることなんですけど
めちゃくちゃパワフルなツールになります
実際に僕が野望リストを活用した例を
ちょっと紹介しながら
お話しさせてもらいます
それがパラ卓球協会のお仕事です
パラ卓球協会の仕事は
ロゴとポスターのデザインという
とても規模としては小さいものでした
予算も潤沢になかったので
本当に小さい小さい仕事として始まりました
パラ卓球は
多様な障害を持つ選手たちが
集まっていて
例えば右手がない選手の
右側を攻めるとか
左足がない選手の
左側を攻めるみたいな
結構 お互いの弱点を攻めまくる
みたいなことを選手が言うんですけど
でもお互いの弱点を攻めるというのが
相手へのリスペクト
スポーツマンシップなんだっていうふうに
同時に選手の人たちが言っていて
僕たちもそのスポーツを初めて知った時に
すごく感激しました
そして すごく強いなと思いました
僕たちは
卓球をプレイする
障害者アスリートの障害って
個性だなって思ったんですね
それをうまくみんなに
伝える手段はないかなと思って
この変形卓球台という
アイディアにたどり着きました
変形卓球台というのは
それぞれの選手が感じている 見えている
障害を通して見ている卓球の世界を
卓球の台を変形させて
スケッチにすることで
表現したデザインアイディアです
実際に説明すると
一番左の八木選手は
生まれつき手が短い選手で
手が短い分 ボールに手が届かないので
その分 彼は台の周りを
走り回らなきゃいけないんですね
なので僕の台は
丸く大きくなっていて
人一倍走りまわらなきゃいけない
卓球をしているとか
真ん中の岩淵選手は
左足に障害があって弱い分
一度左側に踏み込むと
踏ん張りが利かないんで右に戻りにくい
だから僕の台は 左側が大きく
出ている台を描きました
一番右の茶田選手は
車椅子の選手なんですけど
車椅子に座っていると
卓球のネットまで手が届かないので
長く感じると言っていたんですね
それで彼女は
こういう台を描きました
というふうに
このパラ卓球の変形台というのは
選手が乗り越えようとしている
チャレンジが一目でわかる
パラ卓球の見せ方としては
今までにないものとなりました
僕らが活動を進めていくうちに
どんどん野望リストっていうのは
膨らんでいったんですね
僕たちは やりたいことを
とにかく書きまくりました
例えば ポスターを１枚作ろうって
いうところから始まったのを
選手20人の形があるから
20枚作りたいね とか
名刺にしてみたら面白いね とか
リーフレットにしたら
いろんな所に置いて
僕たちが説明しなくても
広がるんじゃないの とか
ついには
卓球台を実際に作ったら
どんな体験になるんだろうと
途方もない野望を
いっぱい書き続けました
実際に卓球台なんて
作ったことがないんで
やり方わかんないけど とりあえず
描いてやってみようよっていうふうに
僕たちは進み続けました
僕らの この野望リストというものは
僕たちの「挑戦の道しるべ」として
僕たちを導いてくれるものとなりました
実際に卓球台を
作り始めようと言っても
何をどうすればいいのか
全然わかんなくて
とりあえず ダンボールを
切ってやってみようとか
手探りでやってたんですけど
自分たちの思いを
発信していくうちに
たくさんのパラ卓球を
応援してくれる人たちが
僕たちをサポートしてくれました
本当に大勢の人が
助けてくれました
そしてついに僕たちは
３台の卓球台を
作ることができました
それがこれです
実際に東京2020の
公式台を作っている
メーカーさんの全面協力で
競技用の台と
同じようなつくりを
変形させたという
作り手にしてみると かなり
無茶振りだったのかなって思うんですけど
僕たち結構「これやりましょう」
みたいな感じで
思ったことを言って
それが形になりました
一番下の土台の部分が オリジナルの —
サイズは違うんですけど —
オリジナルの卓球テーブルの
天板のプロポーションになっていて
それが徐々に上にいくにつれて
選手の個性を表現している天板の形に
変化していくという
ちょっとストーリー性のある
アートとしても見応えのある作品に
美しく仕上げようと 頑張りました
僕たちがこの卓球台を作った後も
まだまだ たくさん挑戦は続きました
例えばイベントとか展示とかに
どんどん出そうよっていうふうに
チームで話していたんですね
でも 搬入とか搬出みたいのって
自分たちで４tトラックを手配して
１台 250キロもあるんですけど
それを３台 真夜中に
運び込む作業とかをして
僕たちは挑戦を続けました
しかも１回とか２回じゃなくて
何十回もやりました
全部自分たちで作業をしました
で 僕たちが野望リストに書いたからと言って
もちろん
全部実現したわけではないです
実現どころか
何していいのかわかんないものとかも
いっぱいあります
でも それでも書き続けました
例えば テレビ局に「これテレビで
取材してもらえませんか？」って
売り込みに行ったんですけど
「パラスポーツだけだと
ちょっと視聴率取れないね」とか言われて
断られたりしたこともあります
あと スポーツ文脈じゃなくて
アート文脈で見せられないかと思って
美術館展示したいなとかっていう
野望はあるんですけど
どこからはじめたらいいかなっていうのが
まだわかんなかったりもします
それでも僕はいいと思っています
どんどん野望リストに項目を
付け足していくっていうのが大事だったり
想像を膨らませることっていうのが
重要だと思っています
結構 中には 時間が経ったら
前はできなかったんだけど
いつの間にかできるようになってた
みたいなこともあるんで
大事なのはリストに
自分のやりたいことをちゃんと書いて
誰かに共有するっていうことが
大事だと思います
このプロジェクトは
ロゴデザインとポスターを
１枚作るというところから
始まったんですが
台ができたことによって
本当にたくさんの人に
パラスポーツの魅力を
届けることができました
子供から大人までいろいろな人に
実際に見て 触れてもらって
パラ卓球の魅力を
知ってもらいました
選手と実際に触れ合う機会が
台を作ったことによってできたので
選手へのリスペクトみたいなものを
すごく子供たちが感じやすくなったんですね
それってやっぱり
ロゴやポスターデザインだけでは
絶対に到達できなかったとこだと思うので
本当に台が作れて
よかったなと思っています
僕たちが野望リストに書いたことが
実現したおかげで
ここまでこれたのかなと思っています
「思ったことを言わないのは
思っていないのと同じ」
思ったことを伝えてこそ
意味があるのかなと思います
思ったことを
口にすることっていうのは
人を動かすパワーになります
時に「ずうずうしく」
僕はずうずうしてくても
いいと思ってます
自分がわくわくする気持ちを
人にシェアすることが
何かの始まりになったりすると思います
これ食べていい？とか
これ食べないの？とか
まずはそんな小さな野望から
是非 始めてみてください
今日はありがとうございました